hi there Steve Kaufman here you're
always the Canadian flag behind me it's
a can of the day that's our national
holiday in canada in fact i'm inspired
by my feelings of patriotism and to the
point that i'm going to post links to
the message that our prime minister
delivered to the country in both english
and french our glorious prime minister
i'm not sure why he would be glorious
he's trying to test I guess does some
things that I like and some things that
I don't like but I'd like to talk about
what I'm interested in which is language
learning and we are trying here to
encourage more people to see the value
of language learning and to see that it
really is is entirely up to them as
learners that they needn't be dependent
on teachers or traditional methods that
nowadays via the wonders of the web
there is just a tremendous treasure of
resources content podcasts blogs
learning systems language exchange to
online dictionaries by the web I noticed
now podcasts related to tourism
different regions you can explore
museums via podcast there's no limit you
can also of course import this content
at the link and work on your language
learning if you want there so hopefully
more people get King adults need to be
responsible for their own learning which
unfortunately one of my pet peeves is is
the attempt of of teachers and people
with the teacher mentality to control
learners obviously that happens in
school teachers want to inculcate
learning strategies they want to
inculcate social values which I'm very
much opposed to because just to digress
I think there really is only one value
and that is reciprocity
do unto others as you would have them do
unto you which Confucius said which
Buddha's has said and which is pretty
well universal but beyond that once you
start inculcating values then the
teacher is going to take advantage of
his or her position to force values on
kids when I when in fact there are many
different positions possible on a whole
host of values and this will depend on
upbringing religion perspective point of
view temperament you name so I think
that more freedom in schools would be
good and a greater encouragement for
children to explore language rather than
having to parrot back rules or or
strategies that teachers try to
inculcate in them and I think that
because of the nature of language
teaching in schools people graduate
without any sense of their own
capability of exploring and discovering
and learning languages on their own so
we're hoping that our small effort and
the effort of other people who are are
putting things up on the web that all of
this will lead to more interest in
language learning it's very good for the
brain if you're going to do things for
your brain like Sudoku you may as well
do language learning you're going to end
up with with with more benefits in a way
you know we do share this goal that this
you know during this brief period that
we're on the earth we shared with a
whole bunch of other people in cultures
the more we can partake of these other
cultures the richer our lives will be I
believe not not everyone has to believe
that but at least those that are that
way inclined should realize that insofar
as language learning is concerned their
fate is very much in their own hands the
less complicated is it is the better you
become a better reader by reading not by
reading strategies you become a better
speaker of a language by doing a lot of
listening and reading an increasing your
vocabulary the less we hear from the
link
lists and other theorists the better off
we are I've posted in the past on this
subject have made reference to ruben
alvarez or brazil who promotes the idea
of creating hunger and that if you're
hungry enough your brain will come up
with the tools needed to achieve what
you what you want to achieve so that is
my little diatribe on Canada Day and
look forward to continuing and to do
this and I always appreciate any
comments from listeners thank you five